problema número 11 a continuación se
muestra un enunciado condicional si un
cuadrilátero tiene diagonales
perpendiculares entonces es un rombo muy
bien cuál de las siguientes figuras es
un contra ejemplo para el enunciado de
arriba queremos un contraejemplo es
decir queremos encontrar un cuadrilátero
un cuadrilátero que tenga diagonales
perpendiculares pero que no sea un rombo
es decir que sus cuatro lados no sean
iguales
vamos a ver estas figuras a ver entonces
aquí en la tenemos diagonales
perpendiculares eso está bien y no es un
rombo los cuatro lados no son iguales
este parece ser igual a este y está
igual a este entonces más bien es
digamos un papalote pero definitivamente
no es un rombo y por lo tanto es el
contraejemplo que buscamos está de acá
no funciona tiene diagonales
perpendiculares pero si es un rombo los
cuatro lados son iguales
este es un cuadrado tiene diagonales
perpendiculares pero tiene los cuatro
lados iguales entonces también es un
rombo y finalmente éste ni siquiera
tiene diagonales perpendiculares así que
éste nos sirve entonces
correcta muy bien vamos a la pregunta
número 12 deja la pongo por aquí esta
pregunta pregunta número 12 y voy a
agarrar el color rojo cuáles triángulos
deben ser semejantes es decir deben
tener sus tres ángulos iguales a dos
triángulos o tus ángulos no suena que a
que dos triángulos o tus ángulos no
necesariamente son semejantes por
ejemplo pudiéramos tener un triángulo
tus ángulo así tus ángulos que tienen un
ángulo mayor a 90 grados entonces algo
como de este estilo y pudiéramos tener
un triángulo con un ángulo súper obtuso
muy cercano a 180 grados como algo así
entonces estos son dos triángulos o tus
ángulos pero no son semejantes entonces
la opción
no funciona o si en realidad que estamos
buscando
estamos buscando dos triángulos que
tengan los mismos ángulos queremos que
sean semejantes no congruentes recuerda
que para que sean congruentes deben de
ser igualitos por ejemplo éste es
congruente a este de acá bueno claro
suponiendo que los dibujes igualitos
estos dos solo son semejantes solo son
semejantes a una versión más pequeña
claro suponiendo que los puse con los
mismos ángulos pero bueno lo que te
quiero decir es que queremos encontrar
tres triángulos que tengan sus tres
ángulos iguales va entonces opción b dos
triángulos escaleno con bases
congruentes escaleno simplemente es que
tengan sus tres lados distintos entonces
suena que esto tampoco es suficiente
por ejemplo pudiéramos dibujar por aquí
la base por aquí la base dibujar un
triángulo un triángulo escaleno como así
más o menos y otro triángulo escaleno
como así entonces ahí tenemos dos
triángulos que son escaleno que tienen
la misma base pero que no son semejantes
sus ángulos no son iguales y éste no es
igual este y este no es igual a todo
esto ya que cuando éste no es igual a
todo este de acá entonces la opción b
tampoco es
opción b no es ce dos triángulos
rectángulos no pues suena que esto
tampoco funciona verdad pudiéramos tener
un triángulo un triángulo rectángulo
isósceles como algo de este estilo como
algo de este estilo entonces tendríamos
que este ángulo es de 90 grados pero
estos dos son de 45 x que tienen que ser
iguales y con 90 sumar 180 y pudiéramos
tener otro triángulo rectángulo un poco
más alargado
así en donde este ángulo es de 90 grados
es de 90 grados pero este es de 60 y
estoy acá es de 30
es de 30 entonces ahí tenemos dos
triángulos rectángulos que no son
semejantes entonces la cee tampoco
funciona de esta forma por eliminación
supongo que debe ser la de pero vamos a
ver si sí es cierto dice dos triángulos
isósceles con ángulos en el vértice
congruentes ok ok entonces yo creo que
eso sí va a funcionar
entonces vamos a tomar otro color
ángulos en el vértice ángulos en el
vértice congruentes a qué se refería eso
creo que se refiere a los ángulos en el
ángulo a los ángulos que están aquí como
a la mitad que no son el ángulo que no
es parte de la pareja de lados
congruentes eso fue difícil de decir con
razón le dicen les dicen ángulos en el
vértice pero bueno supongamos que ahí
tenemos 22 pequeños triángulos y sabemos
que el ángulo en el vértice es igual en
ambos casos entonces no sé digamos que
aquí mide x aquí también mide x vale
entonces nos gustaría ver que son
semejantes cómo le hacemos pues déjame
poner a ver este si sos celeste
y este de acá también es isósceles
entonces déjame llamarle a este ángulo
entonces este de acá también es a este
le voy a poner z entonces este acá
también es z y que sabemos acerca de los
de la suma de los ángulos de un
triángulo pues que es 180 grados
entonces en este triangulito tenemos que
x x + 2 es igual a 180 grados entonces
todos es igual a 180 grados menos x y
así que dividiendo entre dos de ambos
lados es igual a 90 grados menos x entre
2 eso es para para este triángulo de acá
y para este otro triángulo tenemos que x
+ 2 z es igual a 180 grados tenemos y
restando x de ambos lados que 12 es
igual a 180 grados menos x y dividiendo
entre dos zetas es igual
es igual a 90 grados menos x entre 2 y
es exactamente lo mismo que yo entonces
ya es igual hace talle es igual a z y
por lo tanto estos dos triángulos de
aquí son semejantes entonces d es la
opción correcta muy bien vamos al
problema número 13 problema número 13 lo
voy a poner por acá voy a agarrar el
color morado arias encima un poquito
bueno no le hace problema número 13 cuál
de los siguientes hechos sería
suficiente para mostrar que los
triángulos abc y debe son semejantes a
ver el triángulo abc y el debe el abc es
este triángulo grande y el debe
es este triángulo pequeño y queremos ver
que son semejantes o sea nos gustaría
ver que sus tres ángulos son iguales
antes de ver las opciones que bueno
dicen varias cosas pero antes de verlas
déjame pensar un poquito este problema a
ver estos dos triángulos ya comparten el
ángulo en b es decir el ángulo a bs es
congruente al tve porque son exactamente
el mismo ángulo entonces para ver que
estos dos triángulos
semejantes bastaría a ver que nos
digamos este ángulo de acá es congruente
a este ángulo de acá y este ángulo de
acá es congruente a este ángulo de acá y
para ver eso para ver eso bastaría que
la recta de fuera paralela a la hace
entonces aquí vamos a ver vamos a
ponerle que que nos gustaría que estas
dos fueran paralelas esto es más o menos
lo que se me ocurre a mí a lo mejor
estoy súper equivocado pero pero esta es
una muy buena idea verdad si esta recta
fuera paralela a esta de acá entonces
tendríamos que haber es una transversal
a las dos paralelas y por lo tanto el
ángulo aquí con el ángulo de aquí serían
ángulos correspondientes y por lo tanto
congruentes y lo mismo sucedería aquí
abajo veces sería transversal entonces
el ángulo en c sería correspondiente con
el ángulo en e y entonces estos dos
serían congruentes pero bueno vamos a
ver las opciones congruentes es recto
paralelos el segmento hace es paralelo
al d
si esto es justo justo lo que yo quiero
entonces pedir que hace y de sean
paralelos nos permite
concluir que los dos triángulos son
semejantes muy bien los problemas número
14 problema número 14 vamos a ponerlo y
vamos a leer que dice a ver a
continuación se muestra el paralelogramo
abc de muy bien a bs de es paralelogramo
entonces ave es paralelo hace de ibc es
paralelo a ade va entonces es
paralelogramo
la pregunta es que par de triángulos se
puede mostrar que son congruentes para
demostrar que el ángulo de ave es
congruente al ángulo bcd ok entonces
queremos que el ángulo que el ángulo de
ave este de aquí sea congruente al
ángulo bs de bs
s de entonces que par de triángulos se
puede mostrar que son congruentes para
demostrar que esos dos ángulos son
congruentes bueno pues tenemos que
encontrar triángulos que involucren a
esos ángulos si no pues no no nos va a
servir ver que esos dos triángulos sean
congruentes para mostrar esta igualdad
vamos a ver qué opciones tenemos
el triángulo adc y el triángulo bsd son
congruentes o sea mostrar esta
congruencia de c con bs de bueno el bcd
si tiene este ángulo que queremos verdad
tienes este ángulo de acá entonces este
si sirve pero el adc adc tiene nada más
este cachito en realidad no abarca todo
el ángulo que queremos entonces esta
opción no va a funcionar
sí porque no no tenemos este dos dos
triángulos que tengan los ángulos que
necesitamos saber la b b el triángulo de
a de no ha puesto otra vez y no verdad
que el eje de no tiene ni este ángulo de
acá ni este ángulo de acá entonces esta
opción tampoco está buena
a ver la opción c el triángulo de ave de
ave y el psc de bcd si eso se ve
bastante más prometedor porque este
ángulo está en el de ave este ángulo
está en el bcd entonces si lo lográramos
mostrar que este triángulo este
triángulo de acá es congruente al de
abajo
de bs
d
entonces tendríamos que esos ángulos que
queremos son congruentes entonces la
opción se suena muy bien déjame
encerrarla en un círculo entonces
supongo que esos dos son los congruentes
que nos piden pero nada más para no
dejar vamos a ver la tele a ver si no es
una mejor opción entonces de el
triángulo de ese y el b y el de ese y el
b y así parece que son congruentes pero
una vez más pues no involucran los
ángulos que queremos entonces estoy aquí
no va a servir y por lo tanto la
respuesta de la pregunta 14 es c muy
bien vamos a dejarle hasta aquí por el
momento en el siguiente vídeo vamos a
resolver más problemas